You're about to start lesson four in the
mini-course. Again, I'm Alex Lyon and you
haven't yet subscribed, I encourage you
to do so and check the rest of the
videos on the channel out. On this
particular video, like the last one, some
people don't like a couple of the tips
because, if you fall in this category, you
might feel like well that's a lot of
structure and I don't normally
communicate that way.
Well, that's true. Not everybody
communicates in a structure, orderly way.
But, it is one of the best ways to sound
more concise, clear, and confident.
So give it a try.
Check your self-talk and motivation. Why
is it that you don't want to communicate
this way? Because if you can get to the
bottom of your inner thoughts, then
you're much more likely to succeed and
communicate a clear fashion.
So, let's jump right in.
In our last lesson, we looked
at concise statements. In lesson four, we'll
look at organized thoughts. Concise tip
number four. Organize your thoughts into
clear points. This is, of course, one way
to remain concise but it also adds an
incredible amount of clarity and
confidence to your message. Messages
without a clear structure are very hard
to follow for your listeners. And long
lists dilute each item's value. You've
probably sat through presentations where
somebody had 20 items are on a list. And
there's really no impact there when you
have that many items. Much better to
create fewer clear points. A clear
organization shows clear, confident
thinking. Here we have a messy desk and a
joke I pulled from a comic. If you think
this is bad, you should see the inside of
my head. It's actually looks a little bit
like my desk. And, I'm all for creativity.
However, once we're sharing our thoughts
with somebody else, once we're
communicating, we really have to stay
more structured so that they can follow
along with what we're saying in a clear
and understandable way. Richard Fineman
said it like this. "If you can't explain
it to a six-year-old, you really don't
understand it." And the idea here is that
if you really understand something, you
can explain it in a very clear and
structured way for your listeners.
They talk about being able to give a
freshman lecture on a concept and if you
can't give a freshman level lecture, then
you don't yourself understand it. So this
structure will help us clarify our own
thoughts and help it land for other people.
Structure provides a schema or a mental
framework that helps keeps thoughts
clear for you, helps your listeners
follow your point. It gives your message
cohesion or an overarching arc and helps
everybody remember. Strategy one is to
break messages into two to three chunks.
For example, let's say you're having a
conversation about getting healthy and
you want to share this information with
somebody else. Instead of just rambling,
you want to break it down into clear
points. For example, you could talk about
diet, exercise, and the importance of
working out with a friend. And underneath
each of those themes, or some people call
them buckets, you would give your detail.
So, if you're talking about diet, you
might talk about counting calories or
weight watchers, etc. Under exercise, the
different options, and under working out
with a friend how you would hold each
other a little accountable for staying
on track. I was talking to a friend of mine and,
it's a real life example, and I talked
about his retirement plan. He's retired
and he said, 401k, I have some rental income,
and a little bit of Social Security.
Instead of giving a long-winded,
disorganize, rambling answer, he was able
to give me clear themes and then we
continue the discussion about each of
these three items. And he provided some
nice detail. I was watching a movie about
a disabled man from Ghana many years ago. And he had one good leg and one disabled leg.
And he finally got a meeting with a
community leader. And the leader said
what are your priorities? And he said, I
want to help provide independence,
mobility, and sports for the disabled
people in Ghana. He had just a moment to
break the ice with an extremely clear
message, and to this day, I remember this
documentary film. He communicated in that clear and confident way. And I instantly
thought, Wow. This guy really knows what
he's talking about. When we do this, we
want to organize our chunks, our main
points, into some logical
pattern. A nice logical pattern is going
to help people remember and it's going
to clarify our thoughts for ourselves.
Before-after, problem-solution-benefit,
cause-and-effect, steps in a sequence or
in other words chronological, etc. Lots of
different options here. You're not
limited to this list but it's nice to
have a list handy. For example, let's
practice with this stream of thought
example about somebody's day. I got up
got ready a breakfast and worked out. I
did some shopping on the way home from the gym. I bumped into Katy at the store,
she wants to get together tonight. I
actually got some work done during the
day, shot some videos, did some editing, and organized the tools in garage. I was
hoping to get together with Katy and
John tonight but I also have some people
to get back to, some calls to make, at
least a couple of texts to stay on top
of some things. So, this sounds a little
bit like rambling but you can basically
follow it.
It's much more clear, however, if we
structure this into main points. For
example, chronologically. Morning,
afternoon, and evening. And each of those
items has a few details underneath it.
Those themes provide a really great way
to clarify your message, make it much
more concise, and it'll sound very
confident compared to a rambling
disorganized message. It's handy to have
a list like this around when you're
preparing for meetings, important
conversations, and certainly
presentations because you don't have to
create this from scratch. You can invent
new ways but there are lots of great
scheme is already available for
structuring your ideas.
Strategy number two is to then state
your road map. So you have your structure
and now you want to forecast those
points aloud with key words only. So a
physician might say to you,
"Let's talk about symptoms and then
treatments." Now you have a roadmap for
how that conversation is going to go. And
I recommend also calling out your points
along the way. So, let's say you start
with symptoms. You talk about that for a
few minutes and if you are the physician
then you might say, "Now let's turn to your
treatment options." And that'll be a
really clear signal that you're shifting
gears and it again reminds people of that
schema, reminds them of your buckets, and
helps your message state clear. So
structure provides freedom even though
it seems like it boxes people in. We go
back to mindset that we talked about in
the earlier lesson on long-windedness.
Why are we long-winded? Sometimes people resist
applying structure because it feels too
restrictive. It feels like it's robbing
them of something. But there are a lot of
benefits and there are freedoms that
you can experience within a good
structure. First of all it eliminates
tangents, which is good for your thinking,
and it's good for listeners. They don't
want to hear tangents anymore than you
want to get off on them. But it also
provides a place for more details. So if
you have clear main points, then you can
find some nice details and sort them
into the relevant place and then they'll
make sense. And it gives even long
stories a sense of cohesion. So let's say
you tell a five-minute story that's
disorganized. It's going to feel like it
lasts forever. If you tell a five-minute
story with a clear beginning, middle, and
end, then everybody will be able to
follow it and it won't feel long at all. So
structure is a tool to help you sort
need-to-know information versus nice-to-
know information. We talked about this in
an earlier lesson. If it doesn't fit into
your structure, either you have the wrong
structure, the wrong main points, or it's
just not need-to-know information. It
might be just something that's nice to
know, which is why it doesn't fit in. And
that way when you communicate with
listeners, you're giving them high-value
information with every sentence. So we
want to organize our thoughts into clear
points. Our take-away strategies are to
break ideas into two to three chunks and
then state your roadmap really clearly
before you share your message and then
remind people of your points as you move
through them. So our task is to apply
this in conversations, meetings, and
presentations that you have coming up in
the coming days and I look forward to
seeing in the next lesson on effective
pauses.